okay folks so today is the last video
you'll ever need to see on Occupy Wall
Street because today's video is firstly
I will be on Huckabee this Saturday and
have some new Fox clips uploaded to the
channel but I know I've done a lot of
videos here on the Occupy movement and a
lot of folks said why are we paying
attention to this well let me tell you
why I think it's important because
culturally as I think Christian Toto was
writing it one of the big sites occupy
has jumped the shark Americans are sick
of it it's costs taxpayers plenty of
dollars these people are filthy they're
dealing with diseases and what I think
is great is it's forced people now to
look back on the whole hippie era and
realize that those people were just as
stupid as these people are now we've
essentially been able to accurately
rewrite history that the media had
written for us with these whole
effective flowerpower movements when
everyone now realizes that just like the
Occupy movement it was all a joke John
Nolte has created a great list the
official occupy rap sheet that I
recommend everybody go check out
documenting well over two hundred crimes
including a rape drug abuse drug dealing
and some resulting in deaths but those
aren't really funny so I just want to
show the best movements for us to get a
laugh here's one this gentleman
defecating on a cop car because nothing
says political protests like
incontinence folks here's a nice little
one that happened up in Canada
individual number one that's the name
they give to a certain rabble rouser
they don't want a name decided that it
would be funny to hang a feces urine and
blood covered blanket over our tent it
was later revealed to us that the blood
on the blanket belonged to an individual
who may be infected with a communicable
blood disease because nothing says I'm
engaged in political discourse quite
like aids I love this one because this
gentleman assaults a police officer and
then the police officer goes out of his
way to chase him down and beat him up
you don't mess with Carl Winslow let's
look at the TV friendly version of that
[Music]
three two one one two three what the
heck gets bothering me I'll tell you
what's bothering you Carl occupy filth
bags now I like this one a lot because I
was actually there physically in Denver
while this happened running his head
into the car seeing a hippie beaten up
was everything I'd hoped it would be I
will [ __ ] for no man alright then you'll
just get your head knocked while you're
being shoved into a paddy wagon so what
have we learned from this movement folks
well of course it's crime ridden it's
unruly its filthy but folks you can't
expect the members of a movement to be
lawful when these people are breaking
the law as the very first step of their
movement setting up in public parks
where they don't have permits to be so
when you say hey that law doesn't apply
to us we don't respect that law well all
of their laws become subjective and we
also learned that you don't screw with
Carl Winslow
[Music]